je ne suis pas ce qui se passe dans la
tête de supplication parce que quel
courage il faut pour aller sortir ça sur
des de la gueule d'un chien parce qu'un
chien qui me qui a taxé comme
extrêmement dangereux
moi ça me bouleverse évidemment il ya il
a eu un témoignage de beaucoup beaucoup
de gens et notamment de mes personnages
de marvel il ya 4 et d'amérique acquis
qui lui a rendu hommage
ça c'est ça c'est la classe regardez
[Applaudissements]
j'adore alors on a on a un chauffeur à
la table on étend sur deux minutes cgc
jean pascal
j'ai commencé il était sauveteurs en mer
d'aller sauver déclic
il a sauvé des vies ben voilà bien sûr
mais c'est une alerte à malibu moi
c'était plus arrête le malibu ce ne
l'était mais c'est consommer avec
modération en batracien
vous avez des gens pour de vrai avant
d'être pompier j'ai sauvé la vie à trois
enfants mais j'ai été décoré de le
courage et dévouement et leur nounou qui
vous intéressait c'était pour l'estac
ont peu d'intérêt sur la plage sur la
plage pendant j'étais pompier ou sur ma
dernière année ah ouais ouais bon c'est
fait ce que l'europe était appréciée
même pas le sien d'abord il aurait porté
toutes les conneries que je peux aider
dire en tant que chevalier puis après
voilà parce que pas parenthèse on doit
oui dans l'édition tu nous fais de bien
faire mais on est on est retenu dans le
casting il se foutait éperdument de
savoir si vous aimez chanter ou part des
torts mais j'essayerai gta pour photos
de façon que même après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
3 984 maillot merengue revel de la
musique j'aime mon bras monaco
mesdames si vous avez un problème on a
sauveteurs et acceptable qui pourra y
ait pas beaucoup